hi everyone first off I just want to
know who's here so how many of you were
undergrads okay almost all of you uh
freshmen Wow okay sophomores juniors
seniors okay and how many of you were
sort of thinking about becoming an
entrepreneur or starting a company kind
of getting into all that okay cool
okay so thanks for having me it's really
nice to be back in Stanford as Tom said
I graduated over a decade ago so it's
been a long time this building was not
here you guys are really lucky it's
really nice and it's not every day that
I get invited to speak for 45 minutes
about myself it's a weird thing to
happen to you and student habits die
hard so I procrastinated and didn't
really prep for this talk until about
last night so I have my cheat sheet
right here so when I thought about what
I wanted to talk about what I wanted to
share with you I asked myself what would
I want to hear if I were a student in
your place today and obviously things
are a lot different when I was a student
here but I thought a lot of these things
could translate and so I went down
memory lane and sort of thought about
you know my college experience and
remember that it was awesome
like I love Stanford but it was also
really stressful I can remember the
exams the problem sets the coding
projects the biking in the rain with the
plastic Safeway bag over my bike seat
and then you know really hoping I got a
job interview at Google because if I
didn't I'd be a total failure to my
parents and it was just really stressful
and sum it up I had absolutely no
aspirations of becoming an arch burner
like zilch none at all
but Here I am today in front of you
talking about entrepreneurship so how
did it happen it happened through a
series of interesting opportunities very
unlikely I call myself an unlikely
entrepreneur because I didn't come out
that way and I I wanted to kind of give
you this sort of executive summary about
myself where I you know wasn't building
computers when I was six and I wasn't
starting businesses when I was twelve
you know not even a lemonade stand I
played in the
I was shy I was really insecure I was
quiet and I grew up in a you know an
immigrant family and so I was there and
now I'm an entrepreneur I've not as shy
as I used to be I've sold a company to
Google I still occasionally like to play
in the dirt and I'm now running an
engineering team and I start up that's
helping old people so not the path that
I thought I would take but I kind of
wanted to give you a sort of a snapshot
into how I got here so that maybe that
will inspire you to sort of find your
own path so first sort of Revelation is
that you don't have to come out of the
womb with a startup idea and a computer
so I've met a lot of founders through my
career and a ton of them have that itch
like as soon as they're born they're
they pop out of their mom's womb and
they're like I gotta start a company I
was totally not that way whatsoever I
grew up in Maryland and East Coast - yes
Maryland - immigrant parents from Taiwan
and they came to the United States to
find jobs to go to graduate school and
so I was born as a first-generation
Chinese kid in a very typical suburb in
Maryland and I was shy like I said I was
quiet I followed all the rules I got
straight A's I came home on time I did
my homework I played piano I went to
Chinese school I graduated top of my
class I got straight A's like I did
everything that you're supposed to do I
just sort of follow the path and my
parents are really lucky I never went to
that rebellious teenage phase so I was
like the easiest kid possible not
someone you would think would you know
move off to the part of the country and
help old people one day so not not
really what what it was in plan and I
kind of pretty much did everything with
the flow and you know according to plan
and so when I was applying to college I
through Stanford in as a longshot I was
like there's no way I could make it you
know I'm like this average kid you know
did really well in school but you know
what's so special to my high school
and so when I got accepted and the
possibility became real that I could
like go to California and leave home I
was really torn because I'd always
follow the safe path like I got the good
grades you know I did want parents want
me to do and my parents were gonna pay
for my education and so it was really
expensive to go to Stanford I had a
scholarship to go to my local state
school and so I was kind of weighing the
pros and cons and I was like I don't
know should I do it and ultimately
something kind of clicked and I was like
well not every day you get is Stanford
and the doubts were kind of trying to
push my like want to go to Stanford away
because you know Stanford is like we're
super smart kids go and like I'm smart
but I'm like that's smart and so it was
just sort of this dream I was like oh my
god the scream kept him real and so
ultimately I decided okay let's do it
and my parents were super supportive
although my dad does joke that he could
have bought a really nice sports car
with all the tuition money you could
have saved if I went to Maryland because
you know it's pricey here and so that
single decision where I decided to go to
Stanford was probably the single most
important decision of my life it set me
on a path that would not have happened
if I had stayed in Maryland and I often
kind of talk about and think about what
my life would have been like if I had
not come out to California and I have to
say it would be super different I'm
pretty sure I would not be an
entrepreneur I wouldn't have had the
opportunities to push myself the way I
did here and I think the the
capabilities and the potential that I
have realized now would have never sort
of materialized and so sort of a key
lesson for me and to impart to you all
is that one an opportunity like that it
presents itself
don't take the safe option like go and
push yourself to take something that's a
little bit scary because you just never
know where it's going to lead so fast
forwards you want about to graduate and
this wonderful building was not here but
most of my classes and various
activities were at gates and so I was
walking through gates
turn in an assignment or something and I
spied the name's Larry Page and Sergey
Brin name tags on an office door and
this was back in the day when they had
they'd become famous from Google but
they still had an office at Stanford I
saw it dates me a bit it's a little bit
old but that was sort of like you know a
big deal and when I walked by I was like
oh my gosh it's Larry and Sergey you
know nerdy celebrity sort of awe and
what was interesting was that when I
when I saw it it was so unreliable
unrelatable to me that it was just sort
of like oh like a celebrity sighting
because being sort of a real lives to
looking about a founder seemed
impossible it was like they were so
these magical beings that had some you
know sort of interesting combination and
rare combination of plenty of skills and
brains and an ingenuity to sort of start
a company and that seemed so impossible
to someone like me who was shy and
insecure and you know didn't think she
deserved to go to Stanford and things
like that so you sent us such a trend
here when I was not very secure about
myself and didn't have a lot of
confidence my abilities and so you know
that that sort of feeling of
untouchability of those folks really
kind of put a mental block and what I
thought I was possible of doing and so I
graduated in 2003 and this was shortly
after the first internet bubble burst in
a spectacular fashion and if you
mentioned the word startup people would
think you were an evil person who's
trying to take their money and so I
landed a great job at a software as a
software engineer at a semiconductor
company and I worked it for a couple
years
and I sit there in my cubicle and I'm I
think I'm like 23 or something and I'm
thinking there I'm eating my lunch time
like okay I got a great education at
Stanford we're taught that we can change
the world
I'm 5-2 sitting in this twenty square
foot space surrounded by six-foot
cubicle walls and I was like what the
hell
because I was like what am i doing right
I was like having this midlife crisis at
age 22 and I was like I'm I've done all
this work I've gotten the good grades
I've gotten the good school I've gotten
a good job but like I'm not happy like
what am I doing here and so I talked to
my boyfriend the boyfriend who I later
married and who's my husband and he had
chosen a very different path so he was
already doing a start-up with his
co-founder and he did started it as when
he was still in school so he sort of
graduated and sort of jumped right into
a start-up land and he he and I were
talking and I realized when we were
talking that he had flunked the same
test that I did he had no business
background at all yet he had acquired
funding in a period of time where it was
really difficult to get fun to me
because the startup environment was so
bad he wasn't I mean he was smart but he
wasn't like a genius and he's basically
as dumb as I was in a lot of ways and so
I was like well he did it I can't I do
it and the difference was that he didn't
have that mental block he said I'm just
gonna go do this as opposed to what I
had was there's no way I could do this
and so that was really eye-opening for
me and I was trying to figure out like
why was he so like happy and enthused
and engaged in his sort of work and I
was just not happy whatsoever and so I
tried to shut the shy high school kid
part of me out and tried to channel the
let's go to Stanford me more because
that part had been sort of nurturing a
little bit more of that brave bravery
and courage throughout my college years
and that part ultimately won out and so
I bought I got my butt into gear and
opportunity knocked in the form of a
partnership with a friend of a friend
who wanted to start a venture and when
he asked me if I wanted to join I was
like hell yes so it was brings me to my
next point which is that everybody has
impostor syndrome and I may have sounded
really gung-ho but I was absolutely
terrified I was like scared
I had said yes but I had no idea what I
was getting into I know no idea how
startups worked I had no idea how
fundraising worked I had no idea how to
build a team had no idea how to do
anything and yet I was like just keep
going because why can't I do this right
and I want to pause and really make this
a point because the thing that really
crystallized for me was when I saw
someone that I could relate to do
something I thought was impossible and
so accessible role models is really
really important and I think one of my
goals too you know coming here and
talking to you guys and I always make
time for students is that the unbeatable
untouchable sort of founders that you
hear in the news are kind of untouchable
and unreachable but there are plenty
founders that are sort of normal folks
who just like you or sitting in a class
listen to someone talk about
entrepreneurship you have a lot of
potential who never realized that
potential and so for me it was really
important that I saw my you know he's
not dumb but I called my dumb my dumb
husband do the same thing that I wanted
to do and it was like okay someone else
could do this so I could so can I so and
consequently at the end of the day
what's the worst that got happened right
like I try something for two years I
fail you know it doesn't go anywhere and
I go back and get another good job and I
go back on that path right so the
consequences of failing weren't as crazy
as you know I had my high school self I
told put myself and I think you know a
lot of us tend to overthink these things
we list all the I'm sure all of you have
like head to a giant decision and you
list the pros and cons and you make a
like spreadsheet of like what's good and
what's bad and then you kind of
calculate all the odds of what's the
best decision that you can make and I
kind of think of it as the choose of
your own adventure book you know when
you were a kid and you like stick your
fingers between every single storyline
that's possible and then you find the
one that you've already read that wasn't
good and you think the best one I was an
optimizer and I as a kid like that was
what I wouldn't wanted to do and so that
kind of person generally tends not to
trust their gut because there's no data
ink gut it's kind of a raw feeling and
so I decided to shut all that out right
and trust the gut and then
really proved to myself that I could be
an entrepreneur and I could be a really
good entrepreneur and so through you
know getting to know my co-founders it
wasn't like we formed a team like the
idea just like shot into our brains and
then we got funding and boom we're like
we're startup like no no nothing works
like that it took two years of sort of
failing and you know exploring ideas and
coding up prototypes and then getting
disillusioned and then you know almost
quitting and then succeeding a little
bit killing ideas and then a lot of
learning to sort of get things up and
running and all the while I was still
really uncomfortable and I was really
scared cuz you know you're still just
because you say I'm gonna be at
entrepreneurs it doesn't mean all those
insecurities go away and so even after I
quit my job and I was like I'm committed
to this and I you know was like okay I'm
gonna use my savings in eat junk food
for the next two years it was still
really terrifying like I kept thinking
okay man what if someone ask me a
question I don't know the answer to or
you know what if I'm not smart enough to
do this when it's not good enough like
what if this what if that and that
sometimes that chatter just got really
loud and so one interesting story I want
to tell is it got really really loud
when we finally got lined up to pitch to
Sequoia Capital I'm sure a lot of you
have heard Scoy yeah it's a pretty good
VC I suppose they you know funded Google
and Yahoo and all those folks and so we
each had our part in the presentation
and my part was to explain the
technology so oh my god right I got this
so I like studied for hours like you can
like it was an exam I was like okay what
are the coding decisions that we made
were the bugs that we fixed like what
are the what are the design decisions I
made why why did I architect this way
you know what are the like giant you
know coding
obstacles that you had to overcome and I
was like alright I got this I got this
and I was really really nervous
we practiced and we practiced because
you're basically in a room full of
billionaires like generally older white
men and I'm like five two I said I look
like I'm 18 so I'm really young at the
time I won good outfit which I recycled
for all
my pitches and you're sitting there
thinking okay I'm gonna ask these people
for a lot of money and then I was like
there's no way they're going to ask me a
question about memory management why am
i stressing about memory management and
that moment of sort of realization was
sort of amazing to me because I kept
thinking I'm a fake I'm gonna posture
I'm not good enough but I built the
product like I did the work so no one
knew that product better than I did so I
wasn't an imposter I couldn't be I
couldn't be standing here if I weren't
what was an impostor and so that sort of
quieted the chatter a lot and there are
the sort of key times in my career and I
think what happen to you guys where you
have all the self-doubt and you have all
this hesitation and then something
crystallizes where you like why am I
thinking that way and those moments are
extremely powerful and so I tend to sort
of stock those up so when I do feel
insecure or I do feel doubtful I can
kind of remember back to when I was able
to overcome that so what I want to say
is that everybody thinks they're not
good enough at some point in the careers
actually this this plagues a lot of
young women as well there's always this
feeling like I'm not good enough I got
here because this excuse for that excuse
and it's not that you can't feel that
everybody does it's sort of how you
overcome that how you get over that and
move forward that's really important and
the the thing that I want to sort of
emphasize is - you got to give yourself
a chance to succeed you got to give
yourself a worthwhile shot and don't
shut it down before you even have a
chance to try so we're winding a little
bit - before we started to pitch feces a
lot of folks are always interested in
well okay I have an idea I want to do a
start-up like what do I do and the thing
I want to emphasize is that ideas are
really cheap if you think you have a
brilliant idea 30 people have already
had the same idea 20 people are thinking
about working on it 10 people have
already started working on it and five
people probably launched variations of
it so no one's special and there is no
successful entrepreneur who's been
really successful because they had an
idea they're successful because they
being able to execute on the idea so a
lot of young entrepreneurs I've talked
to are really nervous about sharing
their ideas because they're like oh my
god I have this really cool idea I don't
want to share it someone might steal it
and I treat it like this like really
fragile baby and they wrap it in like
winter clothes and like fleeces and like
no one can see my baby
but like all babies babies love running
around naked
that's all they want to do and so your
idea needs to run around naked and the
reason I say this is because ideas don't
grow in a vacuum ideas only improve if
you get feedback and so when we had the
idea for me beau it was through a long
series of failures and I'll go over that
but we asked everybody what they thought
because if you don't ask you're never
gonna find out right and so like I said
the idea is not unique because many
people have that idea but it's how you
craft the idea how you improve upon it
how you work on it how you grow it
that's really important and when ideas
are thrown around elsewhere in the
country I think a lot of people will
tell you why it's gonna fail like oh my
god you're crazy why are you doing that
that's never gonna work or why are you
quitting your job pursue your silly
startup and what's special about here is
Silicon Valley and Stanford in this
community is that people here tell you
how to improve the idea they riff on it
they tell you oh my god if you did this
and be really cool or have you talked to
this guy he had a sort of similar idea
you might go to get ideas from him and I
think what's special and amazing about
this place and why I think you know we
reinforcing the the point I made where
going to Stanford was sort of the best
decision in my life is that this is a
very unique environment Silicon Valley
nurtures crazy people like it nurtures
it encourages you to sort of follow the
unbeaten path or go nuts on some weird
idea because that's where innovation
happens and I think one of the best
pieces of advice I would give folks who
ask me should I move out to California
should I go and like you know move out
to the west coast and like talk to aunt
Rosa I would say yes because there's
nothing like putting yourself in a place
where opportunities can grow and a lot
of times you never know what's going to
happen unless you try
so back to me beau when we started the
you know the venture idea of wanting to
start something we started with like a
Dropbox like idea kind of didn't get
that much excited about it
timing wasn't right took a lot of money
and the thing that we figured out was
that if I'd rather go out and like have
dinner at a restaurant then code
probably wasn't like the greatest idea
in the world
so we killed that idea and then we ended
up doing something more like a media
file sharing program think sort of like
Napster esque if anybody still remembers
Napster for sort of family files and
then kind of decided well downloads are
kind of dying and Web Apps for the kind
of way to go and so kill that idea and
the point here is that we kind of
stumbled upon the idea for me bow which
I think have you actually know what me
bow is okay like three people so
amazingly me bow was instant-messaging
for the web and so this is like a dumb
oment for all of you since everything's
a lot of these days in mobile but this
is before cell phones before like the
browser became really powerful and so
what Meebo did was our tagline to to the
VC's was we're bringing instant
messaging to the web like hotmail
brought email to the web like that
really dates the time period that I'm
thinking about and so we didn't sort of
evolve into that idea until we learned
from our failures on the previous ideas
and so instead of sort of trying to nail
down the perfect idea
you're never gonna that's never gonna
happen on the first try you're gonna
you're gonna sort of explore something
you're gonna kill something explore
something kill something and then
eventually that's going to get you to
something that you're really passionate
about so don't wait for the perfect idea
because there are no perfect ideas and
generally speaking the idea that you
first come up with would never be the
one that you launch with that's pretty
much like the norm so next point make
yourself uncomfortable and so a great
analogy that my co-founder Seth likes to
use is that doing a start-up is like
jumping off a cliff and trying to build
the airplane around you before you die
and so you can land and it's very
accurate
the starting the company is sort of one
point in time of your journey running it
is a totally different beast totally
different beast and totally different
ballgame and so when MIMO got it serious
a you know we we got money and there's a
sort of a notion that once you get the
money fundraise you're like done you're
like yes I made it that's so not true
like that's when the that was the easy
part the hard part is actually running
the company like doing the company and
when people give you money they expect
you to do something with it
generally speaking get a office space
hire people pay people like build a
product you know like do stuff with it
and that's the hard part and so remember
I'm like 23 24 at this point and I know
like jack-shit about hiring building a
team managing a team running a company
like nothing and I was very
uncomfortable but like I did before you
keep going and you learn and so so many
times I hear from young entrepreneurs
that they need a little bit more
experience I need to like do for
startups where I'd start my own or I
need to take this class or I need to go
talk to this guy before they can do
something and I didn't do any of that I
was thrown into the deep end of the pool
and I was expected to swim and I think
that some things sometimes the best way
to learn and so when I was thrown in I
learned how to build a team like a
really good team I learned how to
operate I learned how to talk business
strategy I learned how to hire and I
slowly gained confidence and like I said
before confidence is extremely powerful
and so when my like shy high school
persona would have totally freaked out
my sort of confident entrepreneurial
aura took over and tried to be calm and
learn and you know move forward and I
remember when I had to interview a few
senior hires for me but like the first
sort of senior crew that we had to Ted
to bring under the company and like I
said I look like I'm 18 I'm usually
wearing a t-shirt and jeans and I'm
super short so I did not look like a
senior leader of a company
and I remember though that I had gained
confidence myself I had comfort a lot
more than I thought I could and so I
proceeded to interview like a ton of
people who are way older way more
experienced than I was and you know
guess what they joined like Mevo became
almost 200 folks where we we'd sold to
Google so we were doing something right
mm-hmm and the thing I'm actually most
proud of you know besides sort of
overcoming a lot of my insecurities and
fears was that I was able to build a
really good team like that team was
really special to me some of those folks
I was able to pull into my current
company and honor and so I've worked to
some of these folks for more than a
decade now and a lot of these a lot of
these engineers actually I've pulled
from college directly I've plucked out
of different arts of the country and
we've had this really great relationship
for a really long time and they've you
know gotten married and had kids now and
so the the journey that I've taken also
has brought along a really really
awesome set of people that I've also
taken along with me so the next part is
there's more than Google and Facebook
and the reason I say this is I think
when I was a kid
I'm not kidding when I was a student
here like the big names for sort of my
you know Microsoft that the usual
Microsoft Apple Google and if you didn't
get an interview or you didn't get a job
there it was like you weren't good
enough and I'm here to say that you are
plenty good enough if you don't go to
those companies after we sold me about
to Google
I got a first-hand look inside of Google
and I'd never been in a company's
largest Google obviously my first
company was not that big and I'd
basically had my formative working years
in a crazy little startup that I had
started so I had no experience sort of
understanding what that kind of machine
looked liked mm-hmm and I was really
curious and Google is a magical place it
it's full of free food there are
engineers for miles there are those
toilets that make your but really toasty
when you sit down like that super cool
and I found a really big sense of relief
when I got me boat to Google because you
know arguably Google is the only one of
the best software companies in the world
and I had landed you know my team there
and hopefully things would turn out
really well and so if I were really
smart I would have just coasted along
you know I got a great paycheck really
enjoyed those toilets and you know kind
of had like a good cushy life but I
didn't even though I didn't set out to
be an entrepreneur I became an
entrepreneur and so that mindset was now
burned into me and it was who I was it
was how operated is how I thought it's
how I sort of saw the world and mm-hm it
took a decade but I sort of had that
entrepreneurs confidence and it really
chafed at Google I was really surprised
Google is an amazing place to work but I
was really hooked on the pace and the
impact that I had at my previous startup
and because I couldn't move as fast it
just bothered me more than I thought it
would and again though I was like well
I'm gonna have kids soon Google has like
this great maternity program like I get
a great paycheck going everyday like sit
on the toilet you know like get my free
food and just like relax but I came home
every night and I was like god I'm not
happy and something's really wrong and
so I kind of fell back into that trap
where Google was the safe option it
would like make everybody like it was
like the best thing for everybody and
again it was my husband that kind of
woke me up again cuz he was like look
sandy if you don't quit right now I
wouldn't do it for you because you're
unhappy and you're making me miserable
so that was sort of another kick in the
pants it was like okay I like Google I
like this team but ultimately this is
not the place for me so I left after
about a year and call it a quarter like
a year and a half or so I took some time
off and that time was actually really
valuable for me because if you think
about it I did you know there was Google
for a year and a half or two there was
me beau for seven years there was the
other company for two years and then
there's college and so I didn't really
had no time off since high school so I
took the opportunity to watch like a lot
of bad TV I did no startup work at all
and just hard to try to get my mojo back
and kind of you know we said and some
months past
I was like well should I do another shot
of plague do I have the itch again and
the answer was definitely yes I still
had more in me that I wanted to do I had
wanted to have more impact I you know
really needed to sort of just reset
figure out what I wanted to do and so
when my current co-founders of honor
freed up we you know kind of regrouped
and we decided to dive right back in and
so an interesting point I want to make
is as a second or third time
entrepreneur you have a lot more
experience obviously because you've done
a lot and you have better tuned
instincts then the first time around
and as first-time entrepreneurs which I
think a lot of you would like to be the
excitement of being an entrepreneur it's
kind of like a shot of adrenaline so
it's third of the sustained adrenaline
shot that kind of like rides you through
the first startup because you're just
like full of energy full of enthusiasm
you can work like 40 million hours a
week and you're just like crazy and
later on that it definitely kind of
wears out but the adrenaline is replaced
by you know sort of more efficient
muscles
you know better thinking a little bit
more pause when you act and a lot more
experience which is actually really
helpful and for the the second startup
it was actually a big deal to decide to
jump back in and the reason I say this
is that you know the average they say
the average lifetime of a startup is
about seven years so if you're gonna
think about doing a start-up and really
committing to it you should really
commit seven years that's usually like
seven years till some sort of you know
exit event or whether it dies or
succeeds or whatever and it's a
commitment it's sort of like you're
trading off social time family time you
know personal time to really commit
yourself to this venture because
ultimately you're responsible for your
team the product you're you know you
have a fiduciary responsibility to your
investors things like that
and so when we decided that we were
gonna jump back in we kind of had these
sort of like stipulations of as the
first-time entrepreneur Meebo was really
exciting it was really cool is you know
social media esque stuff but it didn't
have like the world impact that I think
and honor had and when I wanted to do it
again I really wanted
more impact I was hungry or I was
prettier for you know to make a bigger
difference in the world because I have
these skills and I had these things that
I had learned I really wanted to use
them for for better and so the four of
us got together and we're like okay
we're really picky what do we want to do
and so we decided that we need to meet
three criteria and the first one was it
had to be a huge market so a huge market
translates to a huge impact so if I
picked a small tiny market like people
who liked purple cars like that's a
really tiny fit so the demographic that
I can work with as opposed to senior
care which which can affect people
worldwide so huge market the second idea
of the second it's for stipulation was
it really had to help people right like
I can I can argue how meebo you know in
the beginning helped you know facilitate
communication between friends and family
and opened up you know chat networks for
folks who couldn't get online but the
end of the day it wasn't like it was
like changing someone's life and so we
wanted something that I could look you
in the eye and be like I made your life
better and then the third one which is
interesting is that we wanted it to be
an execution risk and so the way we
think about it and this sort of
framework was my co-founder came up with
which I think really resonated with all
of us which was think about a spectrum
of a start-up there's market risk and
then there's execution risk and market
risk is kind of like snapchat where did
the world really ache for a messaging
platform that had messages that expired
after three seconds I don't know like
who knows like I have no distinct
advantage over all of you to figure out
what that what I thought that would work
so there's this sort of market risk of
wool if I build it like will they come
and on the other end the spectrum
there's if I build it execution risk
well I build it they will definitely
come but it's really friggin hard to
build and so we wanted this end of the
spectrum because I have no we have no
inherent advantages over folks like you
who understand like what eighteen year
olds want on their cell phones I have no
idea oh my god the type of wood that's
speeded what you guys text is amazing
but on this side like I had a lot of a
lot of sort of experience I knew how to
operate I knew how to hire I knew how to
get resources
we had connections in the BC space I
could get funding and so we really
wanted to skew this way and so if you
sort of think about all three of those
criteria we kind of listed like giant
problems in the world like unemployment
poverty education child care senior care
we even joked that we could like get a
VC to give us money to buy out a third
world country and fix it we had two
grand aspirations but then we all to me
decide we didn't want to move to a third
world country so we kind of killed that
idea but that was the scale at which we
were thinking about and so my co-founder
Seth went to Connecticut to visit his
mother and his mother sort of had a
Leadfoot her whole life and got a
speeding ticket in Montana which is
really hard to do and she was driving
really slowly and so he was like well
what's wrong mom and he's like well
drivings a little harder than it used to
be he's like holy crap like what am I
gonna do yeah you're getting older you
can't drive as well you live in
Connecticut I live in California like
what am I going to do and so that kind
of keyed us in on the on the senior
space and so when we kind of started to
dig and dig and dig it was turned out
that was like a really interesting
problem that we could solve and so we go
into the senior space and I'll get in a
little bit about honor and a little bit
but one of the things I think that was
actually really unique for me was that I
had made a lot of mistakes at me beau I
first find mantras you don't know what
you're doing you're learning as you do
you're in the deep end of the pool
you're learning how to swim you're
building the airplane at the end of the
day the airplane was kind of like
lopsided and one wing was like really
far out he was kind of like you know
gimpy and the wheels weren't really like
there and so as a second venture I had
the chance to sort of plan out how I
wanted to build the airplane as I jumped
off the cliff and that was really
exciting for me to learn from my past
mistakes and one of the interesting
things was that during the Google
acquisition for me beau during the last
sort of stage of it you do a lot of
sitting around and waiting because it's
not actually particularly glamorous you
they asked you for documents and you
give the documents and so you kind of
sit there and wait for that those
responses and we literally sat down and
stuff and I wrote down all of the
mistakes we had made and what we would
do differently
so when we started on ER we literally
took that list back and said okay let's
do all these things so it was a way
they're sort of like reset and learn so
a little bit about honor the mission
basically is to care for our parents so
pretty sure none of you are super in
that market right now maybe some of your
grandparents are but it's an extremely
personal space everybody we talked to
has some personal story whether it be a
loved one a grandparent a friend a
neighbor who's gone through this where
home care itself is an interesting
industry has not changed in 30 years
the space is worth a lot of money it's
like 30 billion dollars alone but it's
really broken and so when you put a big
market size with a really broken
industry entrepreneurs are like drooling
so we were really really excited to jump
into the space it's been an interesting
journey because it's so different from
social media like we came in knowing
nothing about home care and now we're
really really good ask for experts in
home care and I find it a lot more
rewarding one of the interesting things
is by the end of the me Bou run and when
we had sold to Google when someone asked
me what me boat did it took me like a
paragraph to explain because it's like
well it's like this messaging platform
with like this like social media bent to
help like publishers do this or that it
was just really complicated so it's
really hard to sell but when people ask
me what I do now I'm like I'm just
trying to help your parents it's this
really simple really really mission
based statement that I can make and feel
really confident about when I go out and
sort of talk to people about honor and
the thing is that I'm not 23 anymore I'm
36 I have a family so my risk profile is
a lot different than it was when I was
24 and what I find really exciting is
going to be different from what you guys
find exciting and I went so far away
from social media now because at the end
of the day I realized in that world I
was working really hard to make an
advertiser an extra $2.00 when someone
clicked on an ad and I just didn't feel
like that was something that I really
wanted to continue doing and so when I
had the opportunity to do something new
I really wanted to flip
flip that coin and go all the way to the
super mission-driven you know super hard
super challenging but really really
worthwhile venture because when you like
I said when you commit yourself to a
startup and you commit yourself to a
venture it's grueling it's a long time
to put yourself in one project with one
team and there's a lot of ups and downs
like people say and for me it was the
possibility to make like a lasting
impact on the world
I don't think me but really did that and
so for me it was really rewarding to
finally go to an industry where I could
do that so for you guys I mean a lot of
you were probably not interested in home
care but I would say the advice I could
give to you is that when you're
contemplating in a future startup or
even when you're if you're not really in
a entrepreneurial mood and you want to
go just get it you know get a job you
did a great job pursue something
different look beyond the surface right
there are plenty of other companies that
do awesome things besides the googles
and the Facebook's and homecare on the
surface is not sexy but we solve a lot
of sexy problems really sexy problems
and so a lot of industries have these
really interesting challenges that
require you know engineering thought and
ingenuity that you all have and I think
that would be a boon to different
industries as well so
oh so this is Seth and me in 2008 I
think and that is me and Seth a decade
later at honor so we are have a lot more
gray hairs which I cover up with dye
Seth does not but it's sort of an
interesting like snapshot into sort of
how we've how we've grown grown up a bit
I guess cool and the other point I want
to make his head you might be a little
young for this but you can have a kid
and do a start-up at the same time so
honor is about three years old now and I
had a baby in year one Seth also had a
baby in year one and so it is possible
and clearly I have another one on the
way so it's not like this is not
preventing you from having a family and
I was the way the reason I say this is
that we've had kids you know a lot of
the is really interesting a lot of the
engineers that came over with me from me
bow to honor when I plucked them out of
school weren't you know or my age or
younger they all have kids now too
and they're you know they're working at
honor and honor is still the fastest
moving most aggressive fastest milestone
reaching company have I've ever been a
part of or worked with which means to
say that we're still moving really fast
we're still you know pushing ourselves
we have families we have mortgages we
have you know social lives but at same
time we're very focused and so like I
said before where I think a lot of first
time entrepreneurs are just running on
adrenaline we're trying to be a little
smarter about how we do things and
work-life balance is hard like I'm just
gonna tell you right it's hard there's
no magical formula I'm sure a lot of
moms in here understand that and I'm and
I had to learn how to be a mom and a
founder and I didn't realize a lot of
the challenges how real they were for
working moms until I became one right
and it's even harder when like you have
to you have to you have two babies you
have you're fit you're human baby and
you have your company baby and you had
to take care of both and the the
pressure of you know being responsible
for the livelihoods of your team like
you know honor has you know a large
number employees as well that does weigh
on you right and so the thing the point
I'm trying to make is that you know the
insecurities they come back especially
when your mom the doubts the fears all
of that still running inside me all the
time and sometimes it gets really loud
but you just have to keep going right
you have to serve on the prize to focus
on what you want to get done and then
you know bounce that out and sometimes
that balance comes at a cost but it is
possible I know a lot of founder moms
who've had kids while they were trying
to fundraise while they're trying to
hire and you know pop out babies while
they were trying to you know get out of
a hole or you know raise debt or
whatever so challenges always happen
there's no
perfect timing but if you really want
something you should just go and get it
let's see so last point is that when I
looked up back look back at my career it
all really started again like I said
it's multiple times when I decided to
come out to California and it's really
amazing how sort of these seemingly
small decisions I guess it wasn't that
small but these decisions sort of take
you down different paths so my final
piece of advice is oh wait actually
before I get that
I brought my infant to the office a lot
because I couldn't get childcare and
then that stuff with my son when he was
just a few months old so it is possible
stop listening to me and go do something
opportunities open up all the time
you just have to keep an eye out for
them and you got to put yourself in
situations where that occurs right if I
had stayed safe tucked away in my little
suburbia life and stayed you know done
done what I wanted like sort of the safe
path none of these opportunities would
have opened up for me and I would never
be I wouldn't be standing here in front
of you today and so my advice is to tell
your shy high school self to shut up and
buckle up
so I really like to end these talks with
this slide because I think it's a really
good summary of the points I'm trying to
make everybody has doubts you know time
he's like I said timings never perfect
things are always scary and there are
plenty of entrepreneurs who are not the
like crazy Mark Zuckerberg Larry Page
you know like Bill Gates types there
plenty who are like me who trying to
balance a kid and startup and a really
long commute and you know we just want
to make a difference in the world
and so a lot of you here sitting here
you know listening to me I'm flattered
that I'm here in front of you but I
can't tell you how to be an entrepreneur
I can't tell you how to go pursue the
things that you want to do I can only
tell you like sort of my story and how
that hopefully that inspires you to you
know kind of get your buttoned a year
and do a little extra things here and
there to kind of open up those
opportunities for you and ultimately you
have to pull the trigger right you have
to make the decision
to go and act and so you'll hear a lot
of talks from different entrepreneurs in
this series and I think hopefully a lot
of them will inspire you as well but at
the end of the day it's up to you but I
was like to say if a shy short quiet kid
from Maryland suburbia can do it you can
too so thank you
[Applause]
yes questions
[Music]
so at the time there was like a well so
at the time there was like I don't know
anybody who's ill anymore AOL messenger
Yahoo MSN
ICQ like all sorts of like all sorts of
networks and all of them had sort of
these janky apps but we were the first
ones to actually bring a more seamless
experience like you could actually just
like drag and drop windows around which
is now is like whatever but back then it
was like oh my god
and so we didn't actually like go and
pitch any pcs until we launched so we
literally just let it out wild so people
could test it and that was the way to
get traction and by Tommy had a bunch of
users then the beast' users were like oh
hey what are you doing what's that and
then that could became interesting so VC
is now a lot more savvy about strewth
consumer internet and so they generally
expect a walking product with some user
attraction before they will even willing
to talk to you so if you're gonna go
back down the sort of more consumer
internet route definitely don't be
afraid to put your product out there
first cuz that's all the other way to
share the idea to get feedback
the tough question no yet sorry the
question is is it better to form the
idea and then get the group or get the
group and then form the idea let me tell
you the number one thing I get asked
about is how do I find a co-founder so
if you have a group keep the group it's
really lonely to be an entrepreneur by
yourself like I know a lot of founders
who are single founders the burden the
stress all of that on a single person is
just really tough so if you have an idea
great like go find people who are
passionate about it as well but if you
have a group and you're hamid iya that's
fine too
so either way but if you can find a
co-founder or a group of people that you
want to do something with that's
probably I would that's that's the best
way to go just because you can share the
distress
[Music]
how do you that you help their white
planets you see sand filters so the
question was you know as you decide to
commit to a startup do you have to have
the money to cover that risk so if you
don't don't get a job or have to pay
rent and the second question was how do
you know that the product is right so
for the first one obviously if you are
you know on paycheck to paycheck that's
a little bit harder to take the risk
I you know ended up saving some money
too and I didn't have student debt which
is a huge fortune like fortunately that
I had in my life because my parents were
able to pay for my education the thing
advice I give to folks who are trying to
figure out the balance between sort of
spending the money you know sort of
using their savings to go and make that
leap versus getting a job or doing it
part-time is that you need to set a
timeline right and so folks who you know
say okay I'm going to do it for two
years
I need to have a product by this time a
team by this time and I need to launch
something by this time it gives you a
timeline that you can work with so you
can it be plan so if you are strapped
for cash or you're strapped for finances
just set the shutter sorter timeline or
figure out some way to make sure that
you're reaching those milestones and so
it's not some open-ended and big us
venture that sort of just sucks
everything out of your out of your bank
account for the second question which is
how do I know I have the right product
you just don't you don't know if you
have the right product the only way to
find out is to launch something and to
get feedback and even when that happens
you still don't know until you sort of
see success and so that's the that's the
the market risk part that I was
mentioning that spectrum where if I
build it will they come you just don't
know right there's no magical
like why did Instagram succeed and why
does some other company didn't like why
did snapchat become you know become how
it is and how another company that had a
similar idea didn't get there a lot of
his timing a lot of it is the right
product there are certain nuances within
the interface that you just have to get
right and just sometimes sometimes by
accident and serendipity but there's no
general like okay I got it ready to go
you just have to try and see what
happens what are some of the artists or
most frustrating things about learning
front-running honor yeah um I'd say
honor is human messy so at me Bo and a
lot of consumer internet like when you
want to you know test something on users
it's like oh I want to change the color
of this button or oh if I change this
font or if I add this feature like what
happens with users it's not like a
critical end of the world kind of
feature honored we have angry parents we
have angry adult children we have
seniors who have dementia we have folks
who have chronic conditions with people
who are dying and so it's a very
emotionally fraught industry and so one
of the hardest parts is that we have to
maintain a really high client experience
because the end of the day like I'm a
technologist I'm an engineer by training
we'd build a lot of awesome cool tech
but we are a services company right we
present ourselves as a home care company
not a super high tech you know tech
company from Silicon Valley and so at
the end of the day the technology serves
the end human experience and that's been
challenging for us because a lot of us
are used to oh if I just like release
this code and refresh the page boom new
app right like that's not how it works
and home care and so that's probably one
of the biggest challenges for us to to
learn from it's also gonna Smurf
rewarding right because when you
actually like save someone a trip to the
hospital or or some you know adult child
is super happy that their mom is happy
like that's amazing
you